speaking of Donald Trump at Davos Donald
Trump has targeted a 17 year old kid in
a completely incoherent tirade at the
Davos World Economic Forum in
Switzerland I happen to be talking about
17 year-old Swedish climate activists
Greta toon Berg Donald Trump included in
his screed that she quote barely beat
him out to be on the cover of Time
magazine the President of the United
States a 73 year old billionaire is
attacking a 17 year-old autistic kid who
just wants to save the planet this is
where we are in 2020 it's sick it's
disgusting but we're sort of used to the
fact that this is where we are and the
reality is it's going to continue if and
until this guy is removed in November of
2020 ultimately leaving office in
January of 2021 Donald Trump also maybe
even more disturbingly said that Greta
toon Berg should really focus on the
pollution of other countries because the
United States is doing fine which is a
crazy thing to say let's take a look at
the clip and then discuss but what is
your response to beat me Evan Time
magazine what did you hear from were
other world leaders and business leaders
who said that they was actually but I
would have loved to have seen her speak
I did not know and not at all I think
what is I think aspects of it are I
think that some people are they put it
at a level that is you know unrealistic
to a point you can't live your lives we
want to have the cleanest water on earth
we want to have the cleanest air on
earth our numbers as you saw we had
record numbers come out very recently
our numbers are very very good our
environmental numbers or water numbers
are numbers on air are tremendous we
have to do something about other
continents we have to do something about
other
when we're clean and beautiful and
everything's good but you have another
continent where the fumes are rising at
levels that you can't believe I mean I
think Greta auto-focus are those places
but we are doing better right now than
we've ever done in terms of cleanliness
in terms of numbers we have a beautiful
ocean called the Pacific Ocean with
thousands and thousands of tons of
garbage flows toward us and that's put
there by other countries so I think
Greta has to start working on those
other countries so just the fact that
he's attacking a kid is insane that he's
obsessed with Greta Thun Berg it's very
very weird and in fact I've previously
spoken about how it's bizarre how easily
and totally triggered the right is by
Greta toon Berg it's not just Trump it's
a kid who wants to save the planet and
who speaks in a way that inspires a lot
of people to take seriously this issue
of the climate and pollution and climate
change and so many Republicans are just
so instantly triggered by Greta tune
Berg but then Donald Trump said the u.s.
is clean and beautiful and Greta should
be focusing elsewhere that's wrong the
United States is a huge disproportionate
polluter and user of fossil fuels on a
per capita basis it's the opposite of
what Donald Trump says in reality there
are many countries that pollute the
United States on a per capita basis
disproportionately does so but it
shouldn't really come as a surprise that
Donald Trump is spreading misinformation
on this issue because he did say climate
change is a hoax created by the Chinese
to bolster their manufacturing industry
Trump lost out to a teenager who wants
to save the planet for being on the
cover of Time magazine and he's furious
and he's taking it out of her nice
little presidency we have here not
embarrassing at all and then I
remembered Melania Trump Donald Trump's
wife one of her issues was being against
bullying when she was asked what are
what are the key issues going to be
Michelle Obama nutrition and the White
House garden and vegetables and you know
it was one a very prominent issue for
Michelle Obama
for Melania it was going to be bullying
she doesn't like bullying her husband is
bullying a child
her husband is bullying a child who's
doing something good I think it's
important to add but don't even dare
mention Baron Trump's name by the way
that would be completely in totally
off-limits even saying his name is not
allowed the reality around the world at
a global level is that this
seventeen-year-old kid
17 year old Greta tun Berg at the global
level is more respected than Donald
Trump and Trump on some level probably
perceives that people react more
positively to Greta toon burg than to
him when she walks in the room compared
to when he walks in the room unless it's
a hand-picked crowd at a sick of Fanta
Krall II and he can't take it and he's
attacking a kid again it's truly
incredible if you enjoy shows like Shark
Tank or you're fascinated by
entrepreneurs and how they become
successful I've got something really
cool for you to check out the YouTube
channel we're partnering with called up
flip and you can find it at david
pakman.com slash up flip it's a new
channel they're hitting the ground
running with really excellent content
they're uploading new videos all the
time in each video you meet a different
entrepreneur and take an in-depth look
at how they built their business from
the ground up you can examine the
business up-close learn their strategies
for success see what it's like to live a
day in their shoes as an entrepreneur
myself I find this stuff endlessly
interesting I love learning about how
business owners got to where they are
what motivates them what the turning
points were and everyone who's featured
in up flips videos have their own really
cool insights to share but it's content
that's really easy to appreciate even if
you don't have your own business
every entrepreneur on up flip has their
own story to tell they're all
fascinating check it out if you watch my
show check out up flip this is part of a
partnership we're doing with them
they're friends of ours I think you'll
really enjoy their content it's really
different it's unique there's something
for everybody check it out subscribe to
their channel at david pakman.com slash
up flip